[Applaudissements]
bien laisse un peu tomber tes poupées à
ton agile faut s'en aller je sais que
tes parents sont très gentils mais eux à
ton âge ils étaient
partis
viens je ne suis pas encore très vieux
j'ai la passion au fond des yeux mais
j'ai besoin d'un cœur tend mais oh oui
j'ai besoin de te
protéger j'ai tellement
d'amour à te
donner chez moi il y a des
canapés où je
percerai toutes tes
poupées chez moi je
t'installerai le marcher au fleurs pour
te
parfumer chez moi tu auras des violons
pendus au balcon pour te faire
danser chez moi tu
retrouveras tout ce que tu as si peur de
quitter
viens laisse un peu tomber tes poupées
laisse tes livres et tes cahiers la vie
tu sais ça s'apprend au
dehors
d'ailleurs quelque fois tu sors
bienens j'ai peur que ton cœur prenne
froid j'ai peur qu'un jeune maladroite
fasse
mal sans le vouloir vraiment oh oui
méfie-toi des jeunes amants qui ont le
cœur
coupant comme un diamant c'est moi les
tigres son or il y a un chat qui dort un
chien pas méchant
chez moi tu auras le choix enimer un moi
ou bien un
mandiion tu vois mes oncles sont courts
je peux pas
grifer même par
amour chez moi pour tes insendis mais
mon pleine nuit je ferai grand jour chez
moi il y a des Verseau blancs où tous
nos enfants s'endorment
déjà tu vois tout ce que tu veux tout ce
que tu
as et déjà
chez
moi
than